hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his proma to any future
metaphysics Emmanuel Kant has a very
interesting and important discussion of
mathematics in the Preamble uh on the
peculiarities of all metaphysical
cognition specifically in section two
and he's going to go into much greater
depth in detail looking at the nature of
mathematics in the first part but we
want to look at what he's actually
telling us here and the first thing that
he he says is
mathematical uh judgments propositions
whatever we want to call them are in
fact
synthetic and we should remind ourselves
what does this term synthetic mean for K
so it's opposed to the
analytic and with synthetic judgments as
opposed to analytic they are ampliative
that means they they're adding something
they're they're helping us towards
having more increasing the given
cognition we we could talk about this in
a number of different ways and K uses
several different synonymous
descriptions of this the basic idea is
that synthetic judgments are in fact
adding to our stock of knowledge so we
can not just clarify things as analytic
judgments do but we can come away with a
fuller understanding of the matters that
we're concerned with and Kant will
Express this in terms of predicates and
subjects the subject just as a little
reminder is the thing that is being
talked about the predicate is what
you're saying about about the subject or
what you're thinking about what you're
judging about the subject so if I say it
is it is you know a warm day today we
switch it around today uh is warm right
today is a designated time uh that's the
subject that we're talking about and
then the predicate is warm right what do
we mean by that well by comparison other
things we can get into a lot of weeds
thinking about that BC subject and
predicate or I am a 53 three-year-old
man a currently true statement uh will
be false shortly in the future right and
down the line um I designates this thing
here that's me and is a 53y old man
predicate right so a lot of these things
we have to learn
experientially uh Kant thinks that
mathematical judgments are not empirical
but they are in fact synthetic and he
thinks that a lot of
philosophers missed this and this is a
big problem and he says that this fact
seems hither to to have altogether
escaped the observation of those who
have analyzed human reason it seems even
directly opposed to their conjectures so
not only did they miss it they went the
wrong direction thinking that all
mathematical uh judgments are in fact
analytic when in in the reality of
things they are mostly going to be
synthetic though the ones that are truly
or properly mathematical will be and why
did they do this well he tells us it's
because they got mixed up about um some
some key matters having to do with the
what we call the law or the proposition
of contradiction or non-contradiction
um so you know what is this that a thing
cannot be and not a thing cannot be and
not be in the same way at the same time
with a bunch of different provisos right
so he goes on and he says that it was
found that the
conclusions of mathematicians proceed
according to the principle of
contradiction you need that because he
says you want to have apodictic
certainty certainty that you can be
absolutely sure about um and so people
persuaded themselves that the
fundamental propositions the grun right
the things that we build mathematics out
of that they are also followed from
non-contradiction which is not in fact
the case and he says that uh a synthetic
proposition can indeed be
comprehended according to the principle
of contradiction but only now this is
really interesting only by presupposing
another synthetic proposition from which
it follows so you you've got to have
some synthetic propositions in the mix
in the background in order to be able to
use non-contradiction to derive things
in mathematics or in in what we also
call geometry so turning to properly
mathematical prepositions he says listen
there are always judgments a
priori and not empirical because they
carry with them necessity which can't be
obtained from
experience uh and then he says you know
let's just confine ourselves to pure
mathematics ICS maybe somebody would
argue about that is is that synthetic or
analytic and he says let's take an
example this is a very famous example 7
+ 5 = 12 now is 12 contained as the
predicate in the subject 7 + 5 you might
say yeah that's just the way mathematics
works you know uh that's what's so cool
about it that's what's so a awesome
about this discipline where unlike just
about everything else you can be sure
that 1 plus 1 equals 2 or 7 + 5 equal
12 and K's not saying well you can't be
sure about it but you're not getting it
by merely analyzing
Concepts there's something new that is
being added to the picture by saying 7 +
5 subject is 12 predicate over
here so he says um here we go on closer
examination it appears that the concept
of the sum 7 + 5 contains merely their
Union in a single number without it
being at all thought with the particular
number it is that unites them the
concept of 12 is by no means thought by
merely thinking of the combination of
seven and five and analyze this possible
sum as we may we may not discover 12 in
the concept we must go beyond these
Concepts there's the
ampliative uh nature of synthetic
judgments right we must go beyond this
uh these concepts by calling to our Aid
some intuition some
ansha uh applying or you know uh
corresponding to one of them either are
five fingers or five points and we must
Su add successfully the units of the
five given in the intuition to the
concept of seven so our concept he says
is really Amplified or widened M taken
further by the proposition 7 plus 5al 12
and we add to the first concept a second
one not thought in it uh the predicate
contains something that isn't in the
subject this is a perfect example
according to K of a synthetic judgment
now he generalizes from this to say all
right if it works for 7 + 5al 12 that
means that arithmetical judgments are in
fact all synthetic especially if we use
bigger numbers right because we could
say like you know 1+ 1 1 plus 1+ 1
equals 3 and we could say yeah okay I
can kind of see how that all works
together in this way or 1 plus 1 equals
2 but if we're adding you know some some
huge sets of numbers together we
actually have to do the the math we have
to figure out what it is now we're not
doing something experiential or
empirical by doing that as K will tell
us later uh so this notion of
intuition um you know first of all
dissociate it from like a gut sense
which is one meaning of it but we might
also think about the intuitions that we
have of of things in space and time and
K is to say no that's that's not exactly
what mathematics is drawing upon I'm not
actually looking at five fingers and
another five and putting them together
and Counting them up and saying 10 uh we
could do it with any objects we want to
right so that that's one of the things
that's particularly important about it
what about geometry where we're dealing
with things that actually are presumably
in space there's a
spatiality to them he says well any
principle of pure geometry is also
synthetic here's an example straight
line is the shortest path between two
points this is a synthetic proposition
why because what's contained in the
notion or the concept of straight line
just something
qualitative right he says my concept of
of straight contains nothing of
quantity but only a quality the concept
of the shortest quantitative concept is
something additional and cannot be
obtained by any analysis of the concept
of straight line intuition on showing
must come to Aid us it alone makes the
synthesis possible isn't that
interesting to say so similar to how we
can't just use the principle of
non-contradiction the principle that
analytic judgments are based upon right
directly to derive synthetic judgments
but we have to have something synthetic
we also need some intuition coming in
here and now Kant will admit that there
are a lot of things in mathematics that
do seem like analytic principles and he
uses not just principles but
propositions ET and judgments right to
describe these and these it is true that
these exist in mathematics and in
Geometry but he says that what are these
doing what is their function it's not to
actually increase our knowledge it's
just to serve as identical identi
propositions as what uh we call a method
of concatenation putting things together
right Z their method um so a way of
arranging things a way of drawing
further uh conclusions drawing out the
implications of them so he you know
gives some examples of these a equals a
or the whole is equal to itself or a
plus b is greater than a the whole is
greater than its part and he says we can
recognize these are valid but they're
only admitted in mathematics because
they can be presented in some
intuition again we see the importance of
ansha here and he says what makes us
believe that the predicate of such
apodictic judgments is already contained
in our concept and that the judgment is
therefore analytic is a duplicity of the
expression we get mixed up because of
the way we talk about these matters we
must think a certain predicate is joined
to a certain concept and this necessity
inheres in the concepts themselves but
the question is not what we must join in
thought to the given concept but what we
must think together with it and in it
though obscurely so it is Manifest the
predicate belongs to this concept
necessarily indeed but not directly but
indirectly by means of a necessarily
present intuition now again K is going
to explain much more about this in part
one now there is a disadvantage to
philosophy that results from this right
and what is this
disadvantage not realizing that
mathematics is in fact composed of
synthetic judgments and he talks about
Hume here David Hume who awoke him from
his dogmatic Slumber right this is
something where Hume missed the boat
Hume wants to say that
mathematics is not experiential at all
which Kant is cool with um it is AR
priori but it's AR priori because it's
essentially analytic it's a matter of
relations of ideas logic would fit in
there as well logic and Mathematics as
we learn later on can actually be en
large part uh converted into each other
right but going on um what is this this
problem here he
says um Hume imagined that that the
nature of mathematics dependent on
totally different principles on the
principle of contradiction alone though
he didn't divide judgments in the manner
formally and universally and did not use
the same terminology what he said was
equivalent to this pure mathematics
contains only antic but metaphysics
synthetic a prior judgments he says yeah
he was wrong about that and what is the
consequence of being
wrong Hume say or Kant says Hume could
have extended his question concerning
the origin of our synthetic judgments
far beyond the metaphysical concept of
causality and included in it the
possibility of mathematics a priori also
if you do that you could can actually
make a certain kind of progress that
Kant says that he has made that Hume
failed to make and everybody else prior
to them has failed to make as well so
this is not just like a little
digression or just being you know making
sure that you've as we say crossed every
tea and dotted every eye being being
very complete and comprehensive this has
got some pretty important
implications uh saying that Ma
mathematics is composed of synthetic AR
priori judgments when metaphysics
according to Kant is too we can learn
something about these two different
fields by exploring mathematics as he is
going to do in the first part of the
proma